نعود لمتابعه التطورات في غزه من بابها
الانساني ومعنا من رفح رائد نمس المتحدث
باسم الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه
اهلا بك سيد رائد الان الواقع الذي
تتعاملون فيه كهل احمر فلسطيني تحديدا في
مناطق جنوب القطاع حيث تستهدف مواقع سكنيه
ومراكز لاواء النازحين في الوقت الذي لا
يجد فيه هؤلاء اي ماوى اخر
اهلا بكم في الحقيقه طبيعه عملنا الان
يعني نتعامل في ظل ظروف بالغه التعقيد
وبالغه السوء لا سما في ظل استهداف
المنظومه الصحيه بالكامل في قطاع غزه ومع
انقطاع ايضا خطوط الاتصالات التي تمنعنا
من استقبال نداءات الاستغاثه من المواطنين
سواء كانوا من المصابين او من المرضى
الذين يحاولون التواصل مع الرقم الوطني
للاسعاف وهو التابع للهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني ناهيك عن عمليات الاستهداف
المتواصله بحق الاطقم الاسعافيه والصحيه
والانسانيه على حد السواء والتي كلما
حاولت الوصول الى الضحايا والمكروبين جراء
هذه الاستهدافات المتواصله الا ان يعني
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تواصل استهدافها
لهم واطلاق النار عليهم مخلفه ايضا
الشهداء والاصابات منهم فبالتالي تعمل
طواقمنا في جمعيه الهلال الاحمر صيني وفق
بيئه خطره للغايه وتحمل جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي المسؤوليه الكامله عن حياه
جميع الطواقم العامله سواء في الهلال
الاحمر او غيرها من مقدمي الخدمات
الاسعافيه والصحيه طواقم اذا تواجه هذه
التحديات في ظل استمرار المعارك البريه
والقصف المستمر ايضا بالتالي ما الذي تلج
اليه ويتاح لكم كخيارات للاستمرار في
عملكم في ظل هذه الظروف
يعني في ظل نفاد الوقود من اغلب
المستشفيات العامله وبالتالي توقف اكثر من
30 مستشفى عن العمل من اصل 36 وفي ظل ايضا
شح المستلزمات الطبيه والادوات الجراحيه
وادوات التعقيم والتخدير وفي ظل هذا
الاستهداف الكبير لجميع الطواقم العامله
في الميدان الا اننا نواصل العمل في يعني
وفق سياسه ترشيد بهدف اطاله عمر وامد
الخدمات الطبيه المقدمه يعني على سبيل
المثال مستشفى الامل التابع للجمعيه في
خانيونس يعاني من افاد الوقود ويعمل وفق
وفق جد يعرض حياه العديد من المرضى للخطر
بسبب عدم وجود وقود لازم لتشغيل الاقسام
وال التي تقدم الخدمات الرعايه الصحيه
مستشفى القدس ايضا خرج عن الخدمه كما
تعلمون الى جانب باقي المستشفيات التي
تعرضت الى الاستهداف الاسرائيلي وهذا يعني
يفرض علينا تحديات جديده ويصنع العديد من
العقاب الصعوبات امام عملنا الا اننا
نواصل من اجل تلبيه الحد الادنى من
الاحتياجات الصحيه والانسانيه والاغاثه
لجميع الفئات المتضرره يعني كما تعلمون
هناك اكثر من
24000 شهيد اكثر من 60 ال اكثر من 350 ال
وحده سكنيه تم هدمها على رؤوس قاطنيها
وبالتالي هذه التحديات الكبيره تتطلب منا
مزيد من التكاثف مع المؤسسات المحليه
والمنظمات الدوليه من اجل ضمان استمرار
تقديم هذه الخدمات وتلبيه احتياجات
المتضررين والحد من معانه هل تتواصل معكم
اي مؤسسات دوليه هل تستطيعون الحصول على
اي
مساعدات يسمح لها بالدخول في هذه
المرحله منذ بدء دخول المساعدات الانسانيه
العربيه والدوليه من معبر رفح البري جنوب
قطاع غزه يعمل فريقنا التابع ل الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني بالتنسيق مع الشركاء في
الحركه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر على استقبال هذه المساعدات
وايصالها الى الجهات التي المحليه
والدوليه على حد السواء التي تقوم
بتقديمها للفئات المتضرره ولكن تجدر
الاشاره هنا بان هذه المساعدات لازالت
شحيحه ولا زالت لا
تتناسب مع حجم الدمار الكبير الذي تعرض له
قطاع غزه خاصه في القطاع الصحي والقطاع
الاغاثي يعني هناك اكثر من ميون 900000
نازح الان يعانون من مراكز ايواء تفتقر
الى ادنى مقومات الحياه والمبيت السليم
والنظافه العامه وهناك اوبئه وامراض
منتشره بشكل كبير في صفوف العائلات
النازحه مع العلم بان هناك اكثر من 900000
طفل في بين هؤلاء العائلات النازحه وهم
الاكثر عرضه للاصابه بالامراض والاوبه
نهيك عن توقف العديد من المرافق الصحيه
والبلديه وبالتالي هذا يتطلب تدخلا امميا
يعني حقيقيا وليس الاكتفاء بالحديث
والادانه فقطاع غزه اذا لم يتم التدخل
الحقيقي من اجل انقاذه فهذا سيهدد حياه من
بقي على قيد الحياه حتى اللحظه شكرا
لك رائد النمس المتحدث باسم الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه كنت معنا من رفح
شكرا جزيلا